Joseph starts off this hour in Kentucky
hi Joseph welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I've got a little bit of
issue I've got some problems with my
finances and I'm just trying to figure
out I've been listening to your program
I'm trying to fit my situation into your
solutions and I'm just curious as to
whether your program would actually work
for me or if I need some different
advice okay cool
welcome aboard we appreciate you joining
us so how much debt do you have not
counting your home uh not counting my
homeless it was about 198 so let's go
103 okay and what kind of debt is that
I've got about 58,000 to the IRS mm-hmm
and I've got about 25,000 and credit
cards mm-hmm and about 24,000 NA and car
loans one or two cars one mom two cars
one's paid off so one $24,000 car loan
and what's your hunt what's your
household income right at ninety ninety
to ninety-five it would vary between
there
gotcha how old are you 58 okay all right
and you're married I am okay cool good
good all right
um well the good news is you don't know
a lot on your house how'd you get end up
in the Hawk to the IRS ah was out on the
road a lot and just passed tax taxes not
getting filed it like to get rid of the
tax bill or the credit cards either one
I believe I could see my way through
this but wasn't everything kind of
getting me and oh you can do able but
it's painful so are you paying the IRS
anything currently are you on an
installment plan I am NOT yet I have
spoke with them
[Music]
kind of got some numbers on what it
would take over the next seven years I
believe to clear it up mm-hmm
at the same time when I'm trying to
commit to them I've got some of these
credit cards that are slowly coming in
and garnishing on my wife's wages okay
how many how long have actually how many
of actually garnish your wages ah two or
three at this point okay so you got a
bunch of them are way behind oh yeah
yeah so you haven't been paying the IRS
you're paying the car payment you hadn't
been paying the credit cards and you
make $90,000 a year and you only have a
$95,000 organ mortgage those numbers
tell me you guys have been pretty
disorganized yeah not pretty
totally okay fair enough what it is all
right you're good you're good life's
good hey cuz most of fixing the problems
realizing there is one all right so
you're listen you've lived long enough
and you have enough life experience and
dumb people don't have a $90,000 income
so and talking to you you know you're if
I hired you and you were not caught up
in all the emotion of this and I said
your new job for a hundred thousand
dollars a year is walk in and straighten
this mess out you could do it the first
thing you do is you do what I just did
you'd lay out exactly what the details
of the problem are then you would come
up with a game plan to attack those
details and you would take the $90,000
as there as the shovel and you'd sharpen
the end of it and make it really really
efficient meaning we're gonna get
organized oh we're gonna get beyond
organized we're gonna get plain anal I
mean we're gonna get just completely
freaked out OCD every detail and we're
gonna put you on a beans and rice rice
and beans scorched earth budget you're
not gonna see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there and you're
not going on vacation you're broken
deeply in debt to the IRS does that
sound fair oh yeah this is do haven't
been on vacation in ten years now
there's no so are you doing anything now
that's gonna cause more IRS problems or
if you stop that I have stopped that
okay are the taxes all filed yes okay
I'll give you four or five things to do
and you can begin turning this around
and if you'll follow through on those
then you know I think you can do this
number one jump online at Dave Ramsey
comm click on e LP for taxes get with
one of the people we recommend for taxes
and let them negotiate an installment
plan with the IRS you will not do well
negotiating with the KGB I mean the IRS
by yourself okay you got to sit down
talk have somebody sit down and talk to
them doesn't cost a lot of money but a
couple of hundred dollars and they can
cut you an installment plan this is not
a big deal a few hundred dollars a month
I'll put this wolf away from the door
okay then we're gonna sit down and we're
gonna make a list in detail of all these
credit cards and you make ninety
thousand dollars a year and we're gonna
do a budget jump on every dollar calm
and now better than that I'm just gonna
put you through our class Financial
Peace University and give you the one
year membership to the whole thing and
that's gonna hook you up with every
dollar budgeting app and the class on
how to handle money and you and your
wife we're gonna go the class and I'm
gonna pay for it okay I've already
ordered that oh well there you go okay
anyway so yeah when it comes in get the
every dollar budget app out and you and
your wife sit down together and give
every dollar of your income a name
before the month begins stop all
investing of any kind all saving of any
kind temporarily we have the IRS at the
door and garnishments at the door we're
not ready to do investing we got to get
those cleaned up so let's just do some
quick math okay right thirty thousand
dollars out of 90 thousand means you
could live on 60 30 thousand towards
debt in three years makes you 100%
debt-free except your home three years
from today okay
I think you'll do it faster than that
because I think you can cut deeper than
that and I think you guys will look for
ways to increase your income during this
time that's if you keep the car you
might even sell the car and that would
help too that's up to you guys you can
look at that the cars not killing you
the disorganisation has been killing you
right
get your no not be able to pay off
taxes in 30 years women listen to me a
hundred thousand hundred three thousand
right is everything but the house right
/ 30 thousand divided by thirty three
thousand thirty four thousand is three
years thirty four thousand dollars a
year off of ninety thousand income means
you're living on fifty six you can do
that well that's before taxes I know I
know K but fifty six before taxes I'm
putting you on beans and rice man I
wasn't kidding okay you ain't buying
nothing you're getting these people out
of your life that are taking your life
they're stressing you out they're
freaking you out they're affecting your
marriage and you know this is this is a
radical situation and it's gonna require
a radical right turn ready set go
you can do this we'll put you Financial
Peace University is gonna help you you
call me if you need some more help but I
can see the numbers I'm outside the mess
but I can see the numbers and you can do
this